You can see right here, all I said was
hey Claude, I want you to take this
YouTube video and repurpose it into a
LinkedIn X and Instagram post. Then I
dropped in the link to the YouTube video
and shot it off. Not only did it create
all of these assets, but it also found
bugs in its own code and fixed those.
And then we have this folder over here
called drafts, and if I open it up, you
can see that we have building beautiful
websites with Claude Code, which is the
video I gave it. And then in here we
have Instagram with our actual post text
and five visuals. We've got LinkedIn
with our post text and a visual, and
then same exact thing for X. So that
exact workflow right there took me from
having one long-form YouTube video to
having a finished LinkedIn post, a
finished Instagram post, and a finished
X post. And if I wanted to ask it to
generate posts for six other social
platforms, it could because it can use
all of them and understands how they all
work. So today I'm going to be showing
you guys how you can basically nine X
your content game using a combination of
Claude Code and Botato. So right now
when you're creating content, you know
it takes a lot of time. And when you put
all that time into creating, let's just
say a YouTube video, it'd be really nice
to be able to repurpose that content
into different platforms as well. So
what Botato can help you do is it can
create the source, so it can look
through transcripts, websites, PDFs. It
can find inspiration. It can then create
visuals for you, so infographics,
carousels, or videos. And then it can
actually go ahead and schedule that
stuff. So it can post it to nine
platforms, it can create the stories, it
can create the, you know, content
calendar, and we can do all of that
using Botato and automate it with Claude
Code. So you guys saw a demo earlier,
but I'm literally going to set up a
brand new account today. I'm going to
walk you through the exact steps that
you need to do. And basically all we
have to do is get our API key, add our
MCP config for Botato, and then just
connect our accounts and we're already
ready to start creating content in less
than 5 minutes. All right, so the way
that I like to use Claude Code is within
an IDE called Visual Studio Code. Now
you could use this in Anti-Gravity, you
could use it in the terminal, you could
use it in Cursor, but I like to use
Visual Studio Code. So if you don't have
this, then just go to your browser, type
in Visual Studio Code. You can download
this for both Windows or Mac or whatever
operating system that you're on. Now
once you're in here, this is what it
should look like and I'm going to walk
you through everything you need to click
on and everywhere you need to type, so
don't get overwhelmed. If you'd rather
watch like kind of an intro video and
then come back, then I'll tag this one
right up here and then hop on back over
here. And by the way, if you've been
watching my channel for a while, then
you've known about Bloatato. I showed it
in N8N in this video and also in all of
my kind of like faceless shorts videos,
we use Bloatato to do the auto posting
and scheduling. But now I'm just showing
you how it's actually a lot easier to
use with Claude code. So, that's exactly
why once we're in here, we're going to
go over to this left-hand side and click
on the extensions button and all you
have to do is type in Claude code. It'll
be this one right here that's verified
from Anthropic and then you just go
ahead and install this. When you install
it, it will prompt you to sign in with
your paid Claude subscription. Now, this
does have to be the pro or max plan
because if you're on just the free, you
don't have access to Claude code. Now,
once you've installed this, what it will
do is give you this little orange button
in the top right which lets you open up
Claude code. And this is kind of like
your typical Claude or ChatGPT interface
where you get to talk to an agent right
here. And now what we need to do is open
up a project or a folder. So, I'm going
to go over to this top left button that
says explore and it will say you have
not yet opened a folder, go ahead and
open one up and that's where we'll be
working inside for this specific, you
know, AI social media poster project.
So, I just went ahead and I created a
brand new one. I just called it
Bloatato. There's absolutely nothing in
here and this is what your screen should
look like. And now what we want to do is
just basically close out of the welcome
thing. We can go ahead and double click
and then hit the Claude code button and
now we just have our files which will be
on the left. We don't have any yet. And
then we have our Claude code agent right
here that we are going to be able to
talk to. So, what I'm going to do in the
chat is paste in this prompt that says
create me a new skill called repurpose
YouTube video. It's going to create an
AI social media manager that makes
social media posts for LinkedIn,
Instagram, and X. The user will input a
YouTube video URL and wants it, I
misspelled this here, to be turned into
a LinkedIn post, Instagram post, X post
and each one should have a visual that's
optimized for that platform. So
PluralSight is basically going to take
this video and do everything for us. I
end this prompt by saying ask me
clarifying questions one at a time until
you are 95% confident that you can
complete the task successfully and I
kind of use this templated prompt from
Sabrina. So shout out Sabrina. You guys
can all copy and paste this exact prompt
from my free school community or you can
just copy it by looking at it right
here. So now that this is running, it's
going to start going through that
process. The first thing that it's doing
is it's researching about PluralSight to
figure out actually able to do. It's
basically going to help us build out
this flow where we drop in a video,
PluralSight extracts the transcript,
adapts the content for these different
media platforms, and then it creates
everything.
And then we're able to review it and
then just basically approve it manually.
Now before I start going through this
flow of answering questions, I wanted to
explain what is a skill because you'll
notice I asked it to create a new skill.
Just think of a skill like a recipe.
If you tell your agent to write a
LinkedIn post, it would look at the
LinkedIn post skill and that would have
the name of the dish, the ingredients,
the steps, and then the finished output.
That way the agent could read the recipe
and make sure that every single time you
ask it to make that dish, it comes out
perfect. So because we're turning this
process into a skill, every single time
we use it, it's only going to get better
and more consistent. But anyways, now
we're going to come back into Cloud Code
and answer the clarifying questions. So
it's asking me what program language to
build this in. I don't really know what
I want to do here and you may not
either. So what I'm just going to say is
whatever you think is best. It decides
to go with Python because it's the
cleanest for this kind of API driven
tool. So then it asks, should the tool
auto publish or do preview and approval?
I want you to always make sure I review
it before you ever publish anything on
my social media accounts. If you guys
are curious about how I'm talking and
words are appearing, then check out the
description for the tool. Anyways, for
the AI generated post copy, do you want
to use Claude to write the tailored
posts or should the tool just reformat
the extracted YouTube content without an
LLM? I definitely want to use Claude to
rewrite the text content for the
different platforms. Cool. So, we'll
eventually have to give it an Anthropic
API key as well as the Bot API key. Now,
it asks about the tone of voice that we
want. So, in this case, if you had like
a custom GPT or Claude project already
that helps you write LinkedIn posts or
Instagram posts, you can just go ahead
and grab the instructions from that and
put that here. But, for now, I'm just
going to keep this really simple for the
sake of the demo and just say
platform adapted, professional on
LinkedIn, um and on X you can be casual
and maybe even a little bit humorous.
Now, it's asking for Instagram what type
of post should it create? I would like
you to create a educational carousel
that looks like I am writing tweets.
And now, it's asking about the visuals
for LinkedIn and X. For LinkedIn, let's
do a
key takeaway graphic. It should be clean
and it should have some text that
explains the value in the video. And for
X, yeah, let's just do something
eye-catching, maybe a cool quote.
Next question is, how do you want to
review the stuff? Let's just go ahead
and save everything to the drafts folder
so I can take a look at it myself. When
publishing, should you be able to
selectively approve which platforms to
post to? Yeah, I will tell you one by
one which ones have been approved. I
think I nearly have everything. One last
question, should the tool that you edit
the draft text files before publishing
and have the publish command pick up
your changes? Absolutely.
Okay. So, it looks like we're done with
the question stage now. Now, you might
notice that there's still some stuff
that we might want to give to this
platform like maybe some more
information about our business. It
doesn't really know anything about what
we do and maybe things like the colors
we like to use or our logo or something
like that so that it can be on the
visuals. So, now what it's going to do
is it's going to build up those
different tools. As you can see, it
makes it to-do list and it's going to go
through one by one and finish all that.
And also, what you're going to notice is
on the left-hand side, we're going to
start to get files and folders in our
project setup. And that's really
important because if your Claude code
workspace isn't organized and it doesn't
understand where files are. And if you
don't understand where files are, then
it's just going to get messy and it
might be hard to manage the context.
Okay, so that has finished up. You can
see that we have a new project
structure. So over here we have a
PyCash, we've got .cloud with our
commands. So this is essentially the
exact same thing as skills. So this is
the repurpose YouTube video skill that
it created. You can see that it created
some actual Python scripts to draft, to
post, to publish. And so maybe we would
want to clean this up and put this in a
different folder called scripts or
something like that. But the action item
on us now is to actually set up our API
keys. So if I go into the .env, you can
see that we have a Botato API key and an
Anthropic API key that we need to set
up. So the first step would be to use
the link in the description and go to
Botato and that will help you get 30%
off for 6 months. Now once you get that
set up, all you'll have to do is go over
to the bottom left and go to your
settings and then click on right here
API. And this is where it will ask you
to just basically make sure that this is
a paid feature. So if you enable it, you
will be on a paid plan.
And then you'll go ahead and copy this
API key right there. And then in the
.env, you'll paste this in and then you
will save it. And then it's also asking
for an Anthropic API key. I'm actually
going to go ahead and use
OpenRouter instead cuz you can access
all the models there. So I went to
OpenRouter, I created a new key and I'm
going to copy this and paste it into
Visual Studio Code and I'm just going to
tell Cloud Code that I am using
OpenRouter with Cloud models instead of
Anthropic, but you can use whatever you
want here.
So I just cleared the context and we're
about to do a test run, but before that,
I just wanted to show you guys something
that we can do that's pretty cool real
quick. So I'm going to go over here and
I'm going to drop in a new folder and
I'm going to call this brand underscore
assets. Now what I'm going to do is drag
in a profile picture of myself in the
brand assets. It's this profile picture
right here because I want it to be able
to use this in the tweet style
infographics or carousels that we told
it we want to make. So what I can do now
is go to YouTube. I've got this video I
made a a days ago about building
websites in Cloud Code. Copy the link,
come back into Visual Studio Code and
say, "Hey Claude, I want you to take
this YouTube video and repurpose it into
a LinkedIn, X, and Instagram post. I've
given you in the brand assets folder a
profile picture of myself to use in
these, you know, different visual posts.
Let me know when you've got some stuff
ready to review and make sure you're
updating your skill document with your
findings from this first test run." So
now it's going to read through the
skill, it's going to execute these
different Python scripts right here, and
if it runs into any issues or any things
that we told it like using our profile
picture, it will update that skill
document with. And here's an example of
it already needing to make an adjustment
is because it said, "YouTube is blocked
by the web fetch tool. Let me try
alternative approaches." So that just
finished up. You can see that it started
off by reading the skill. It goes
through and it tries different things.
It made a to-do list, and it was able to
create the actual text-based posts, but
what happened was it actually failed on
the visuals. So what it did is it added
a known issues and findings section to
the actual skill itself, but we're going
to go ahead and try it again and we're
going to see if it can fix it. So I just
said, "Try to create the visuals again.
Make sure they are images, not videos,
and we aren't worried about posting it.
We just want you to create the assets."
So it's once again going to dive in
everything. It is going to investigate
the templates, and then it's going to
come back hopefully with something that
we can review.
So visuals have been created this time,
and apparently they're looking great.
And you can see once again it's updating
the skill document so that that never
happens again. Okay, so these have been
created successfully. We've got our
LinkedIn with a whiteboard infographic.
Let me go ahead and open that up real
quick. It's putting all of this stuff in
the drafts folder, and you can see we've
got Instagram, LinkedIn, and X, and this
is all for the YouTube video, which is
called building beautiful websites. So
it's keeping our stuff organized. So for
LinkedIn, here's our visual. We've got a
whiteboard that says building beautiful
websites with Claude code, three key
steps. We've got claude.md, front-end
design skill, and then adding your brand
assets to a folder. And you can see the
bottom it also says full walk-through on
YouTube at natehurk. And then we also
have the actual post right here, which
is the text-based copy of the LinkedIn
post. So, let's say we like that one.
Let's go ahead and look at Instagram.
We've got the same thing. We've got the
post right here with the different, you
know, slides. And then we have the
actual visuals. So, here's number one.
Your Claude dot MD file is everything.
It is a system prompt that runs before
every session. We've got the next one,
which is the front-end design skill. And
then pretty much all of these I'm
assuming are the same. We've got brand
assets. We've got you don't need to be a
developer. And we've got the difference
between Vibe Coded and Professional. So,
the one thing I will say about these are
that I think this would look a lot
better if we had our profile picture as
well as like a blue check mark verified
badge. So, that's something that we'll
probably want to change. And then real
quick just to look at the X post, we've
got the actual text itself, which is
um very casual and it's kind of more
like a meme. And then for the visual, we
just have a very simple quote. But as
you guys know, I want to make those
carousels have the profile picture in
there. So, I just asked Claude Code to
put our profile picture in the carousel
slides as well as adding a blue check
mark. So, we'll see if we can get the
job done. All right. So, look how cool
this is. It fixed that workflow, so it
now should have new carousel slides for
us. But what it did is it actually had
to resize our image because it realized
that the Potato API wouldn't take it if
it was too big. So, this was the
original and then it resized it to make
it smaller, but it still obviously looks
the same. And now every single time that
we run this for Instagram carousels, it
should be able to make it the way we
want it. So, let's take a look. All
right. Here is the new Instagram
carousel. We've got our name. We've got
the verified badge as well as our
profile picture. And so now it would
just be a matter of optimizing the
actual content that's put in here if we
don't think that this was prompted well
enough. And maybe adding one more at the
end, which would be a CTA that says like
follow for more or something like that.
But keep in mind, all I said was take
this YouTube video and repurpose it. We
didn't give it any context about our
business, about previous Instagram or
LinkedIn posts. We didn't give it
anything, but literally just said make
us content. And the only reason I'm
telling you this is because think about
how much better this will be as you
start to add more business context, add
more brand guidelines, and then iterate
and refine. We've ran this workflow
twice, I think, at this point, and it's
gotten better each time. What would
happen if we ran this 10 times? And
every time we gave it more feedback and
more feedback, so that by the time we're
ready to host it, so that if we wanted
to run automatically every time I post a
new YouTube video, it automatically
gives us this stuff, by the time we do
that automatically, it's already like a
really rock-solid or battle- tested
skill. And by the way, in Blo Potato, if
you go to my videos, you can see all of
the ones that you've generated, and you
can also go to the API dashboard to see
all of the requests that you had been
making to Blo Potato. But at this point,
the only thing left to do is schedule
these out or just instantly post them
now that we've reviewed them. So, what
you do is you go to your settings, and
you have to log in with your different
accounts. And it's literally like, let's
say we wanted to log in with Instagram,
we'd click on this, and it would just
bring us to a sign-in page in Instagram,
and it would connect everything very
easy for us. And then after we've done
that, you can see here I've only
connected to my X account, it lets you
copy your account ID. So, basically, it
associates an account ID in here with
Blo Potato to actually post on your
behalf. But Claude code, using the right
API endpoints, should be able to grab
all those IDs for us, so there's really
nothing manual here. So, just as an
example, let's make sure that it can
actually post to X for us. Cool, that
output looks great. Can you go ahead and
post our content on X for us? All right,
so that post is live. If I open this up,
we should see on X that I did just make
this tweet, which I'm going to delete
right now. But just wanted to prove to
you guys that that endpoint does, in
fact, work.
So, at this point, now that we know this
works, we could just build different
skills within this kind of Blo Potato
environment. So, we could build one for
getting inspiration, we could build one
for creating, you know, TikTok videos,
whatever we want to do. But before you
start scaling this up, it's really
important to have some structure to this
project, because we've got, you know,
our Claude with our skills, we've got
our brand assets, we've got our drafts,
but we also have some scripts right here
that are just kind of in the middle of
nowhere. And we also don't have a
claw.md file yet. So, I'm just going to
go ahead and do  init, which
basically just reads through the current
project structure and creates a claw.md
file around what we have right here. And
I assume at this point everyone's aware
of what the claw.md file is, but if
you're not, it's basically the overall
system prompts for this specific
project, meaning every time before you
shoot off a message to Cloud Code or
before Cloud Code reads it, it's going
to read the claw.md file first to
understand the direction, what tools it
has at its disposal, what rules it needs
to follow, things like that. Which means
you don't want to keep your claw.md file
very long. I think best practice is to
keep it under 150 lines. Otherwise,
you're just going to fill up your
context much quicker. So, now you can
see that we have a claw.md file that
goes over the overview, the commands,
environment variables, architecture,
patterns, things like that. Which now,
as you can see, gives our project a
little bit more structure right here.
But, I'm still not satisfied. What I
want to say now is we have four Python
scripts that don't have a home. Could
you throw those into a folder, maybe
call it scripts or something like that,
and make sure that our other skills and
claw.md files
are aware of this and can reference it
in the future. And that's just the way
that I decided to set it up, but you
could also say, "Hey, you know, we've
got a ton of files here. Can you help me
figure out a strategy to clean this up
so we can continue to scale this
project." So, you can see that it made a
new folder, it threw all of the Python
scripts in there, and now it's updating
other files in here to make sure that
the whole project understands where
everything is. So, that is going to do
it for today. I think that you guys
should be in a really good spot now, set
up with Cloud Code, set up with Potato,
to really improve your content game.
Just a reminder that you can access the
resources you saw in today's video, as
well as every other resource I've given
out on YouTube for free by joining my
free school community. The link for that
is down in the description. And if you
want to go deeper with this kind of
stuff, then I definitely recommend
checking out my paid community, AI
Automation Society Plus. The link for
that is also down in the description.
We've got over 3,000 members who are
building businesses with AI every single
day. So, I'd love to see you guys in
this community. But, like I said, that
is the end of today's video. So, if you
learned something new or you enjoyed,
then please give it a like. It
definitely helps me out a ton. And as
always, I appreciate you guys making it
to the end of the video. I'll see you on
the next one.
Thanks, everyone.